[Music] I
had naval forces and there should also
have been safety
ah
until they were talking I
was
[ __ ] amman
sand
at the door
[Laughter]
and
an inclusion
finished
this beauty from sana web know
here
thank you chest
to heal and heal yesterday
scratch
from the current cinema
good
1 wheat
the fac
racing
you have to lose
in the pages of the air
non-stop
álvarez
no you do
at 7 o'clock
in our hand
faults ph
well
condition
it's easy
jets
a fake
6 of
course
nothing escapes the train
ah
me
good
to know
that
for the first time
and they
came
as a guest
you never hide page
jibrín cover
this facade
eyes
to grow
and
then
from the page
this [ __ ] the following there are
christmas
flowers fit
that is
and
[Music]
[Applause]
we
are not going to see
now
gat
for  here
is that
they move
palmor right
now
full of grace
here
you have to know
siemens
page
and the end of miami
I like
here
caracas
me
and
it's called
take out extract
later if you see  to
or so that I want you green
leaving
like today
or there is something between key cities
the sorrows
olano
[ __ ]
the English page
if we have
but in front of her
or not
to this office
that is peace
Camagüey
you
yes to be
and why
don't you stop
fahrenheit
performance
well
the water
[Music]
no
[Music] I
mean
ergo pac
[ __ ] is that
first of that friendship
pac
although by
faction game
wow
ah
this is like jacmel
natural and feasible
by train
this facility
what we can
no
and
[ __ ]
on that scale
i
dt  to
this façade
guadix a lot
[Music]
exactly
why
gat
jumps in game
factory
this peace
oh
enough
and I
step behind
time
yes
as
and it's here
[Music]
oh
the sky would
stand out
and
what for you
10,000 for tourist and digital vacancies
and here it is
[Music]
that's why if I were esteiro
de
afa wherever I went
oops
malaga
santiago
this issue
another woman
these things
have faith carlos
[ __ ] today's session
you can see
well let's see that
's enough
[Music]
mushrooms
facilitated 10
here
later is the expert
webber
marketing of this order
that is to say I
apples
good
to spend the night
and in metal
here
swann
terrible for kenton sanders for
master of colony
what
to move right
now
wilder
in my soler
and 7th
when you
're
after  people
from charging
i
caracas
efe
and my fans six times
this player is desperate
no
let's not see
uff
like poker
to degrees
like i can't
for what
and
then it
's
very 20 pts
and
uff
later he
and
oh
with 12 years
and hence his brain
why
to see
address to you sac
and
me
hello
the young people of bread fire
this young woman salt farc
as
her love
frutillar
because you are going to do
already well she
usually has
to see it
will be a shock away
[ __ ]
yes
expression acadia
christmas
and
we will see
In case the channel
in general
is not easy
here
[Music]
and
someone has put me in, I
fill up
very well that they witness
the kidnapped
[ __ ]
and
kinect
until we have with this n  New topic
nothing
then
and always what is missing is to shut up
from faction
and
we have
here
for the chef to
fish
app the
same
or not
[Music]
he would have stayed first and
you see
it works for many
of aspe h
for fernández
why
cat
now I go
and
what
for  months
count on
or you stay
is it
is all good morals
that is
tertsch egüés
we say
fox spector
the faxes thirty euros
are charged
special
since the pse perseus
uruguay
[Music]
in it
I refused I will
not do it
man
here
the softness beings
jared
vietnam
in león
normal
caracas
and money
tell me
later others
samar
her
maybe
dad
[Music]
and
well
the new life
and
the tastings ph
support we
have to rescue
an outfit
and
yes no
three more months
after arrival
and for me to finish
giving  jaén
state
d
that they attack you
while it's
worth
h
and
I are
going to fix it
well
to steal
if it is to insert what river decade
the farc
good missionary
or
on cnn
m
gore
this goal
tell me
your ex's family
is
hag
only xavi
and
what to
have
yes
for each year
well we
[Music]
finished
explosion focus
with this volume
here
ah
maybe pac
or not
ah
I have arrived
with strength
[Applause]
ok
ah
in the manganas the city
the heads
[Music]
ah
never
[Music]
e
near taca state